mom the number one lesson she would tell
me as a kid is like
in order to have a friend you need to be
a friend and like I say this all the
time I don't have any hobbies in my life
I don't go rock climbing I don't do I
don't collect baseball cards I got
nothing going on about all the stamp
collection
I value friendship I like hanging out
with my boys I like making money I like
hanging out with pretty girls I'm a very
simple dude but to Pat's to basically
what Pat's saying is there's a couple
quotes we can talk about right here but
essentially it's like value those who
um will support you when they have
nothing to gain that like essentially
like
um
who will have you in your life when you
have nothing to offer other than
yourself just being there for you
there's a famous quote by Oprah what's
I'm gonna read the quote she says um
lots of people want to ride with you in
the limo
but what you want is someone who will
take the bus with you when the limo
breaks down so when you have nothing to
offer other than your company that is a
true sign of a friendship